[THEME MUSIC]
MAHLET SEYOUM:
Without further ado,
I'm going to pass it
on to Neil Pepe, who
is the artistic director of
the Atlantic Theater Company
and is also the
director of this show
to give you guys some background
about the theater company
that's actually in this
building and then also introduce
the show.
So thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
NEIL PEPE: Thank you, Mahlet.
Yes, we are in fact
in this building.
We're very excited
to be up here and see
how incredible Google is.
So we are the Atlantic
Theater Company.
We were actually
in this building
before you guys moved in.
We've been around
about 30 years.
We're a theater company
that was founded
by the playwright David Mamet
and the actor William H. Macy.
And we do a lot of new
plays and revivals.
And we have two theaters.
One, you've probably seen
downstairs in 16th Street.
It's our Stage 2, and it's 16th
between 8th and 9th Avenue,
and that's where we
do our Stage 2 shows.
And the other is on 20th
Street between 8th and 9th,
and that's where Marie
and Rosetta is happening.
Some of you may
have heard of some
of the more well-known shows
that we've done at our theater.
"Spring Awakening," the
musical, started with us.
And we do, as I said, we've
developed a bunch of musicals.
We've developed a
bunch of new plays.
We've also done quite a
few authors from England.
We did the Martin McDonagh
play, "Beauty Queen of Leenane,"
which also moved to
Broadway, and the "Lieutenant
of Inishmore."
And we're also-- we
run a big school.
We have a studio through NYU.
And so we have a
three-year program.
And I think we even
have some Googlers who
are taking some of our
part-time conservatory program
downstairs.
So we run a large
school, and you'll
see students coming up and
down the elevator sometime.
Plus we have a kids program.
We're currently running a show
called "1001 Nights," which
is written by Bobby Lopez,
who some of you may know
wrote the "Book of Mormon,"
and "Avenue Q," and "Frozen."
And that just actually
opened this past week
and is going very well.
And it's happening on top of
the set of "Marie and Rosetta"
on Saturday and Sunday mornings.
And so come by and
check that out.
Yeah, we're all about new plays.
And "Marie and Rosetta"
is a great new play.
It's written by George Brant.
I was sent the play last year
from a producer friend of mine,
and I knew about George's work.
George wrote a play
called "Grounded,"
that was at the Public
Theater last season with Anne
Hathaway about drone bombing.
And he's a wonderful writer.
And so I wasn't quite sure what
to expect when I got this play.
And I read it, and I thought
this is kind of extraordinary.
Here is this amazing woman,
Sister Rosetta Tharpe,
who has been dubbed the
godmother of rock and roll,
and I had never heard of her.
And I consider myself
to be a rock and roll
fan and a fan of blues music
and a fan of gospel music.
And so then I immediately--
thanks to you guys, I
went to YouTube.
And I started researching more
about Sister Rosetta Tharpe,
and, lo and behold, there were
all these incredible songs.
And here was this
amazing woman who
started in gospel in
the 1930s and then
kind of moved into more popular
music in the 40s and 50s.
And not only was she
a great songwriter
and a great vocalist, but as
you'll see, if you YouTube her,
or if you come and see the show,
she was an amazing guitarist.
And so in the late 30s,
here was this woman who
took out an electric guitar and
played it like nobody really
played it before and--
what we found out later--
ended up influencing people like
Jimi Hendrix and Chuck Berry.
I was amazed because I'd
been a huge Chuck Berry
fan and a lot of the riffs that
Chuck Berry plays are directly
from Sister Rosetta.
So here was this play that
was not only celebrating
this woman, who
sadly is not known,
but it was also talking
about the history
of 20th-century music.
And it was
celebrating two women,
because it concentrates on the
meeting between Sister Rosetta
and another phenomenal
singer called Marie Knight.
And they got together
and sort of performed
as a duo in the late 40s.
And so the play
concentrates on that.
And what George was able to
do is kind of compress a lot
of factual information
about their relationship
and then show us some of
the songs that Rosetta wrote
and talk a little bit
about Marie Knight as well.
So for us it was a
great opportunity,
because we're all
about telling stories
that we think are
important to be told,
and we're about
celebrating great writing
and the truth of great writing.
This was an amazing
story to tell.
And just the fact that--
well, I should also say we
feel blessed to have these
incredible performers.
The fact that these
women were not known
and then for all of us to come
together and celebrate them
was a big deal for us.
So what we want to do today is
have some of our cast members
and Deah Harriott, our piano
player, do some of the numbers.
We're going to do three
different numbers for you.
And the people who are
going to be performing them
are Miss Kecia Lewis, and
Miss Rebecca Naomi Jones,
and Miss Deah Harriott.
So come on up, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
KECIA LEWIS: Hi Google-- ers.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC - REBECCA NAOMI JONES,
KECIA LEWIS, "DIDN'T IT RAIN?"]
[APPLAUSE]
KECIA LEWIS: So that was one
of their biggest hits together.
And you're going to
introduce the second one?
What are we doing?
REBECCA NAOMI
JONES: Oh, I thought
you were introducing it.
I can.
NEIL PEPE: The ballad.
KECIA LEWIS: The ballad?
Yeah, oh me.
I'm introducing.
Yeah, yeah, I said I was
going to introduce it.
So there's-- something factual
about Sister Rosetta was that
she was very close with
her mother, Mother Bell,
she called her.
Katie Bell Nubin was her mother.
And Mother Bell was
very instrumental
in Rosetta feeling
and having the freedom
to not just sing in the
church where she grew up,
but to be able to utilize
her gifts in other areas
and other genres of music.
And that closeness
was very palpable
between the two of them.
And this song that
we're about to do
is-- in the context of the play,
Mother Bell has recently died.
And Rosetta sees
Marie as someone
that Mother Bell would
have loved to know
that Rosetta was connected to.
So there's a moment in
the play where I tell her
that my mother has died,
and I ask her would you
sing something so that my
mother can meet you spiritually.
So that's what this song is.
[MUSIC - REBECCA NAOMI
JONES, KECIA LEWIS,
"WHILE KNEELING BY
HER BEDSIDE"] whi
[APPLAUSE]
REBECCA NAOMI JONES:
And this last song
is a little bit of a taste
of those kinds of other songs
that Sister Rosetta
was encouraged
to do both by record
companies and also by her
Mother Bell, who encouraged her
to praise in any way she knew.
So Rosetta did go out
into the real world,
as it were, and she did some
records with bigger bands
and stuff that was a little
more-- or a lot more secular.
So in the context of our
show at a certain point
Marie, who has previously
allowed herself
to seem very, very, very sacred
and very afraid of these kinds
of secular songs
reveals to Rosetta
that she actually
loves these other songs
and asks Rosetta to
sing one with her.
Here it is.
[MUSIC - REBECCA NAOMI
JONES, KECIA LEWIS,
"I WANT A TALL SKINNY PAPA"]
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
KECIA LEWIS: It's all good.
MAHLET SEYOUM:: Thank
you guys so much.
I got to see it a
second time, and it's
even more incredible to see
you guys up close and just
in your element.
I have a ton of
questions, but I want
to make sure I give you all
time for questions as well.
And I had a first question, but
after seeing you guys perform
so incredibly, the
first question I
have is about your
musical process.
Music is such a huge part
of this show, obviously,
and I'm not someone who has a
really big background in music,
so I'd love to hear about what
you guys went through, what
the relationship
and dynamic was, a
and what was important
to you in this process.
NEIL PEPE: Well, I should
say, for those of you that
don't know, I mean all these
guys have incredible acting
backgrounds and
music backgrounds.
I knew Kecia's work.
You were in the
original "Dreamgirls,"
"Once on this Island,"
"Leap of Faith."
Last year she did an amazing
"Mother Courage" at CSC.
KECIA LEWIS: It was
actually this year.
NEIL PEPE: This year?
Yeah, it was this year she did.
Yeah, earlier this year.
January.
And so Kecia not only has a
great background as an actor,
but a great background,
obviously, as a singer.
And then Rebecca's
work I knew very well
from "American
Idiot," she was in,
and "Passing Strange,"
and "Murder Ballad," that
was over first at
Manhattan Theater Club then
at Union Square.
And also knew her not just
as a musical theater actor,
but as an actor.
So they both had great
music background.
And then I was introduced
to the lovely Deah Harriott
by Jason Michael Webb,
our music director.
And you guys knew each other--
was it through the church?
DEAH HARRIOTT: Through-- we
just met through musical friends
and in Jersey, actually,
because I lived there first,
and I met Jason there.
NEIL PEPE: And we
were so excited,
because Deah's background
is both classically trained,
but has played a lot
of gospel, right?
DEAH HARRIOTT: Yes,
yes, definitely.
Started playing
gospel around age 7.
Was classically
trained from age 3.
And then just kind of melded
and meshed the two together.
NEIL PEPE: And then, finally,
the one person that's not
here is Felicia Collins.
And she does all the
guitar stuff in the show.
And she was David Letterman's
guitarist-- some of you
may know her from that--
for, I don't know,
20, 23 years, or something.
So the reason I bring up all
these backgrounds in terms
of the question is because we're
talking about Sister Rosetta
Tharpe, who was very much
anchored in gospel music
and then made this transition
into popular music.
And then pretty much
on her own started
developing something that people
later called rock and roll.
The final-- one of the
last songs in the show
called, "Strange
Things," some historians
label as the first
rock and roll song,
even though she cut it in 1946.
So I think part of
our process-- at least
for me-- was to have all
of these amazing musicians,
singers, talented actors,
who could not only
do their jobs as actors and
musicians incredibly well--
and I was so fortunate to have
them to work with-- but it felt
like such a great kind
of coming together
of people who
understood the music,
both the sort of rockier,
bluesier stuff and the gospel
stuff.
And another
interesting thing I'll
say-- which these guys
always-- I mention,
and they hassle me about is I
have no religious background.
And so part of my experience
of working on this play,
not only learning from
the play, but learning
from these guys a little
bit was about gospel music
and about spiritual music.
And it became a very,
very meaningful process
for me both musically and
storywise to get into that.
So and, finally, I would say
the music is so exciting--
and, hopefully, as you can
hear just from the three songs
you heard, but if you get a
chance to see the show itself,
this music still lives.
I mean if you go on YouTube
and listen to Sister Rosetta
or come see this show,
these songs are not dated.
And I think that's one
of the reasons they
felt so ahead of their time.
They're so alive
and and fantastic.
But-- you want to
jump in about it?
KECIA LEWIS: Neil
so eloquently talked
about some of my
musical background.
I grew up in the church, so
gospel music was very much
a part of my life growing up.
And my mother knew
of Sister Rosetta.
That's more her era.
And my mother listened to her.
And as we were in this
process what I discovered
was a lot of the stuff that I
remember my mother humming was
some of this music,
which she would just
hum it doing dishes or
being around the house.
But it's amazing to me.
And again, it speaks to
the endurance of this music
that it feels like we could
have wrote this this year,
and it's very much,
very much alive.
And so for me
working on this music
was very organic to who
I already am and just
trying to figure out how to
bring some of myself to it,
as well as honoring
Rosetta without trying
to copy her or mimic
her in any way,
but to do some of the things
that she did in the music.
Jason was-- as I was
learning the music,
our musical director, Jason,
we had worked together before,
so he knows me.
And he was like, OK, this riff
sounds like you that she does,
so do this riff.
Do this one.
And then this one, that's
not so good in your voice.
So maybe don't do that one.
Do a Kecia thing there.
That kind of thing, you know.
So it was very much
collaborative and able to speak
to who I was as a person,
as well as who Rosetta
was and honoring she and Marie.
REBECCA NAOMI JONES: I
think the only other thing
that I think is worth adding is
that what I loved about working
on the music in this process
was that the way we approached
the songs, of course,
is the way you approach
a song in a musical,
right, so how
is it going to tell the story.
So a lot of what I have
to sing, especially
in the beginning of the
play is very straight.
No riffs.
In fact, some of this
stuff is like songs
that we have-- the recordings
of them, there are riffs,
but we took them out, because
Marie is so contained,
especially for a large
portion of the play,
and so that was really exciting
for me to work on stuff
where I had to really just
use economy with singing
and really just tell the
story and use the words.
And I love the way George chose
which songs go into the play,
because it really allows us
to grow within the music.
I mean it really, like, I
have these quiet, quiet songs,
and then I get to sing
more and more broad stuff,
and then we get to groove
together and cook together,
which is really cool.
So I would say that
would be my journey
with the music in the show.
DEAH HARRIOTT: Oh,
all I'll just say
is that I think that they placed
a lot of faith in our collabo
here, because I
always explain this
like an organized, an arranged
marriage that just happens
to work, because we
all really do get along
and we love each other.
And it's such an intimate
setting, if you see the show.
And to have the two
vocalist actresses
and two musicians it's just--
you're very vulnerable.
And it's just you
and the audience.
So you feel like every mistake
or anything that is heard
is just supposed to be there.
And so I would just say
that it really, really--
just like Rebecca said,
you have to really know
what to take out of yourself.
Know what to add in.
Not add too much.
And in the riffing
age of today, you
have to just water it down
and take all that out and just
be plain and vulnerable, just
let your true musicianship
show.
And you can tell that
we're married, because look
at what we're wearing.
We didn't plan this.
KECIA LEWIS: We
didn't coordinate.
DEAH HARRIOTT:
We're all matching.
KECIA LEWIS: This was creepy.
DEAH HARRIOTT: It was--
it's a little creepy.
KECIA LEWIS: I was like, really?
For real?
DEAH HARRIOTT: What's going on?
What is this?
KECIA LEWIS: We're like
turning into each other.
It's creepy.
MAHLET SEYOUM: So, Kecia, you
brought up the fact that when
you were singing
whether or not you
and the musical director
deciding when to bring in Kecia
and when to bring
in Sister Rosetta
and that that brings in a
really interesting question
around the fact that you
guys are playing real people,
that you could go online.
You could research.
You could watch videos, as
you mentioned, on YouTube,
and you can get
their own essence.
So how much did that
play a role and a factor
in your own process of
taking on this role and kind
of developing in rehearsals?
And how much of
yourself did you bring
of it versus Sister
Rosetta and Marie?
KECIA LEWIS: For
me as an actor I
like to work from
the inside out,
generally, so as I watched her
videos and read some about her
and thought about
who she was, I found
that she and I were very
much alike in a lot of ways.
So I wanted to honor
that part of her that
really was a pioneer,
and she didn't even
know she was a pioneer.
She was just doing
her thing, you know,
and enjoying being a
musician and being a singer.
So for me it was
preparing myself
in a way to bring myself
the parts of me that
were like her to the table.
And Neil as our director told
us from the very beginning,
I'm not looking for you
guys to imitate these ladies
or to try to recreate who they
were, but we're honoring them.
So you bring who you are
and honor them in that way.
And that was very freeing.
And it also helped
me to just try
to open myself up
spiritually to what do
you want me to say about you.
What do you want people to
know about you now in 2016?
And just let that be what
people receive from my end.
So.
MAHLET SEYOUM: Thank you.
REBECCA NAOMI JONES: There
isn't really much out there
on Marie Knight.
There's not a ton of
footage or any of that.
But I did have photographs
and some recordings,
and I think that
stuff always helps.
Just when you see the way a
person carried themselves.
Marie has this pose that
she does in a lot of photos.
I mean like a lot of
photos-- like every photo.
But it's like variations.
It' It'll be like this.
Or it'll be like this.
But it's always at least
one arm is doing this.
But for no reason.
And to whom?
[LAUGHTER]
But it's great, because I saw
in her this delicateness, which
I don't know that I
necessarily carry in my body.
And that helped me a lot.
That informed me.
And, of course, the words that I
speak that are on the page also
indicate that.
But there's a way
that you see someone--
the way they carry
themselves, the way they
wear their clothes that
can really teach you a lot.
And of course just hearing the
recordings are helpful, too.
I mean not in terms of--
I'm not going to change
the way my voice sounds.
She's got a different kind
of timbre of voice than I do.
But that stuff is
just fun to get
into the world of the
character for sure.
Yeah, that's it for me.
MAHLET SEYOUM: Thank you
Neil mentioned earlier
that the Atlantic Theater
Company focuses
mainly on new works,
and this is actually a new work.
It was the world premiere of
this show and of this piece
of work.
Can you talk a bit
about how working
with a completely
new piece of work,
being the premier theater
to bring that to light
and to the stage, how
that differs from revivals
and from works that have
been produced many times?
And you actually worked as I
understand it pretty closely
with the playwright, so can
you talk a bit about that?
NEIL PEPE: Yeah, absolutely.
I mean it's always thrilling
to work on a new work,
because not only are you-- it's
the first life of the show,
and you're trying to figure
out how the story operates.
But it's the first time these
characters have ever been seen.
So with the actors
and the musicians
you're kind of creating this
thing for the first time.
And that's exciting.
As opposed to plays
that you've seen a lot
and maybe you're trying to--
like we were talking about,
find our truth
within those plays.
But to do it for the first
time is a fascinating process.
One connection, because
Mahlet went to Stanford--
we started-- I did a workshop
of this play in a little theater
in Palo Alto called
Theater Works, which
is a wonderful theater
there that also
has a developmental program.
So about just over a year ago,
George and I went out there,
and he had a basically
finished draft.
He was still making
some tweaks, but we
did two weeks of rehearsal out
there with a couple of actors--
local actors-- there.
And had the chance to
kind of do a reading
and sing it in front of people.
But it was our first taste
of how it operated as a story
and really looking at
what the conflict was.
And one of the hardest
things about working
on a play like
this is form wise,
it can take on what people
call a jukebox musical sort
of structure, meaning
you have existing songs
and you're trying to sort
of string them together
with a story.
And one of the things that I
really appreciate, and I think
George is great at
is taking the essence
of this story between
these two women
and where they were
each at in their lives.
Because I think in the
context of the play--
as we talked about
in rehearsal--
they're both at a
crossroads in their lives.
One at the middle
of her career, one
at the beginning of her career.
And both career wise, as
women, in relationships--
they talk about
marriage-- they're
seeking different
things from each other.
And so trying to figure out
that arc and the conflict
and how to dramatize
it, but also
with George, how to make sure
that it was always tight.
And the other thing I'll say
about George as a writer, which
I really appreciated, he's very
much like many great writers,
a language writer.
And there's a rhythm to his
language, which, I think,
again these guys have
taken on so beautifully.
And George will-- when
he was making changes
during this process-- he didn't
make huge changes, because most
of it was there, but
sometimes to great frustration
for the actors, he would
change tiny little things.
And we would be in previews
and Kecia had learned
all these lines and then he'd
change up like two or three
little words, rhythmically--
KECIA LEWIS: Or switch them.
NEIL PEPE: Or just switch them.
Yeah.
So that sometimes can
be the hardest thing
to learn because you've
learn it one way.
But he did it because he
was very cognizant of how
rhythmically it works,
and also, I think,
aware of that same
word, economy.
Because I think George was
very concerned about getting
to the truth of who
these characters were.
And I think he was also--
George being a white man,
he was also very, very kind
of shy and a little insecure
about working on this play
about these extraordinary
African-American women.
And so, I think, in
the whole process,
we were both trying to--
like Kecia was saying--
keep our hearts and
our sense of truth
open to really be able
to represent and honor
who these women were.
And yet, also, as we
were all talking about
try to bring the truth of
who we are to sort of merge.
So a lot of those
kinds of things
you think about when you're
working on new plays.
MAHLET SEYOUM: Thank you.
I actually just recently
read an article,
and I believe Kecia, you were
quoted in it, about George
where he was talking
about just that,
about him being a
bit hesitant at first
about writing a
story such as this,
being as he was a white male.
And you-- correct me,
if I'm wrong-- saying
that you appreciated the
fact that he took that pause
and that he thought about it.
Do want to just
elaborate a bit on it?
KECIA LEWIS: Yeah,
I just thought, I'm
very moved by George
as a human being.
And I don't know him well,
but I spent a lot of time
with him as we were
working on the play.
And the fact that he
was conscious enough
to be concerned that his
perspective as a white male
quote, unquote, and
in this country,
you know him even
being concerned,
what right do I have
to tell the story.
Is it OK if I tell the story?
That speaks volumes
to me about his heart.
And so I think that that very
heart is what's in the play.
And the fact that he is
such a thoughtful person.
There's a section
in the play where
Marie talks about her kids.
And I'm a mom.
And he got it right.
And I was, like, dude,
you don't have kids.
You're not a mom.
You're not black.
Where you get that from?
How did you get that?
He's like, I don't know.
I just kind of thought
that's what a mom would feel,
that's how a mom
would be concerned.
So I think that being conscious
and conscientious about what
you're doing and
the reason you're
doing it that is a huge part.
And George was-- also, another
thing that I love about him--
his whole impetus was why
hasn't anybody told this story?
Why don't I know
who this woman is?
People need to know who she is.
That speaks volumes.
Not I need to write a play about
someone so I can make a dollar.
Or I need to jump on this
bandwagon of African-American--
or whatever people say.
And that just speaks
volumes about his heart
and who he is as a
writer and as a human.
And as an actor it's
just a privilege
to be able to work
with someone like that.
MAHLET SEYOUM: Yeah, I agree.
And on that note.
The play deals--
and for those of you
who have seen it, know-- the
play deals with a lot of really
complex themes, not only about
race, but about sexuality,
about illness, death, but also
joy, and praise and gospel.
So how much of all of that do
you take into consideration
when you decide whether or not
you want to take this role?
Does that kind of excite you?
Is that something that maybe
makes you apprehensive?
Like what is the draw
around those kind
of complex themes in stories?
REBECCA NAOMI JONES:
There's so much draw.
I think any piece of
theater that deals
with more than one
theme is very exciting
and it is the way to go.
[LAUGHTER]
It's easy in what we do,
especially in musical theater
to--
NEIL PEPE: Play one note.
REBECCA NAOMI JONES:
Play one note.
Yeah.
And that gets old and boring
and doesn't turn you on.
And this play turns us on.
I mean there are all of these
complexities within the play.
And the play-- what I love
about this play so much
is that it feels like it's going
to be one thing, especially
if you were to just describe
to somebody what this play is
about-- it's a rehearsal between
these two women, who have just
met each other and they're
going to try and see
if they can become partners.
OK-- that's enough for a play?
That's enough for
a 90-minute play?
Like, OK.
But it's like every
few minutes there's
little pockets of surprises
that come out and that excite us
and that excite the audience.
And it's very rich.
And there's just so much
for us to play with,
and I think the joy of it
is the overwhelming theme.
I mean, I think,
Rosetta talks a lot
and teaches Marie about how
the idea of praising God
doesn't have to be like a job.
It doesn't have to be rigid
and for the purpose of not
going to hell.
It actually should
be a positive thing.
It should be all
about joy, and you can
praise in many different ways.
And I think that is
just so impactful.
And it really I think
it like takes us
all on a journey every day.
NEIL PEPE: I just
want to add one--
All of that-- and
another thing that I find
fascinating about working on
it and working with these guys
is one of the things-- to look
at these two women, who really
they're heroes.
They're unsung heroes.
And the reason they're
heroes is far reaching.
But when you look
at two black women
at that time under
those circumstances,
whether dealing with
racism or sexism
or performing in the South or
men who were taking their money
or whatever was
going on-- the fact
that not only were they
doing this incredible music,
but they were
bringing so much joy.
You didn't see the adversity.
You saw the strength.
You saw the willingness to
embrace the truth and the joy.
And that's part of
the thing that I
find amazing about
watching these two do it.
It's sort of about teaching
each other to have the strength
to tell your own story.
To have the strength to
be who you want to be.
Not to sound too pat about it.
But I think the
fact that they were
able to do that under
those circumstances
and still not-- granted
Rosetta was popular
for a certain period
of her career,
but then really sort of
forgotten since then.
And yet they still did that.
And still have the
strength to celebrate it.
That was remarkable to me and
remarkable about who they were
and why we want
to celebrate them.
MAHLET SEYOUM: Absolutely.
I want to open it up to
questions from the audience.
We have two mics on either side,
so if you guys have a question,
just go ahead and line up.
AUDIENCE: I saw the play just
the day before yesterday.
And I had no idea what it
would be like going in,
but I was just so
happy that I did it.
NEIL PEPE: Great.
AUDIENCE: So one
question that I had
was you mentioned
how you had never
heard about Sister Rosetta.
I hadn't and I'm sure your--
did your playwright George know
about it before?
NEIL PEPE: He knew
a little bit about--
he didn't-- he had heard a song,
by actually a white artist,
Robert Plant, and Alison Krauss
called "Sister Rosetta Comes
Before Us."
And then through his
interest in that song,
researched her and then
ended up becoming obviously
a massive fan and
learning all about her.
AUDIENCE: So a lot of the themes
were in a very private setting,
an interaction between Sister
Rosetta and Marie, right.
I'm just wondering how you
got a lot of the material
and research to write that
play given that they're not
that well-known popularly.
And, of course, you also
mentioned that a lot of it
was you're just not trying
to represent them completely,
but you're also trying
to bring yourself in.
So what parts of it were
factual, and what parts of it
were stuff that you brought in?
NEIL PEPE: I'll try to speak
for George, because it's really
a question mainly for him.
George did a lot of research.
There's a wonderful book
called "Shout, Sister, Shout!"
which is a biography
of Sister Rosetta.
He read that.
He read a lot of other
books about gospel.
He watched on YouTube a lot
of the footage of Rosetta.
And there's a
wonderful documentary
that was made on PBS, which is
also on YouTube in four or five
different parts.
So he did that.
And to address your
question, I would say 95%
or so, even more of
this play is factual.
I mean the basic events
of what took place here
and the things they
describe are real.
The only thing that George
messed with a little bit
time wise is Rosetta's
mother died later in her life
than in the play,
but he felt like it
would be more dramatically
interesting to put it recent.
And so that they could--
that's why Marie ends up
singing that song to
sort of comfort Rosetta
during this time.
But George really
immersed himself in it.
But then going to
the point we made
before, I think
at a certain point
took all of the
factual information
that he had, put it aside,
and then wrote a play,
and wrote a story as great
playwrights can only do.
So it wasn't just about
sticking to the facts,
but how he crafts the facts
that he had into a story.
How-- like we're
talking about-- he
brings his truth and experience
to making that happen.
And then not for nothing,
how to frame up these songs,
because there's a
lot-- you'll find
they did a lot of
amazing songs together,
and George was only able
to use some of them.
I even discovered-- if you
know that Rolling Stones
album, "Sticky Fingers,"
there's a song,
"You Gotta Move," on that.
And it's a song
that these two did.
And I think they
may have even wrote.
Or it's a traditional.
But the way the Stones
do it is exactly the way
these two did it.
And it's kind of
amazing-- you're going,
oh my god, I've known that song
for 35 years or however long,
and in fact, the first
time it was ever done
was these two women, and they're
singing it with such strength,
and, you know, rock
and roll spirit.
So, yeah, George
did lots of research
and then kind of did what
he wanted to do after that.
MAHLET SEYOUM: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: This is
maybe a silly question,
but I noticed on
the poster there,
it says, "world premier
play with music,"
rather than like a musical.
Is there specific reason for
why it's worded like that?
NEIL PEPE: That's
a good question.
We kept going back and forth.
And George originally
called it a play with music,
because I think he thought
of it more as a play that
had songs in it, and now he's
been sort of saying to me,
oh, maybe I should have
called it a musical,
because there is that thing
of-- if you saw "Once," I
mean it's not that
different. "Once"
had existing songs in it,
and they called it a musical.
So I think it was just George.
I think this is the
first musical he's ever
written-- or play with
music-- so I think he thinks
of himself as a playwright.
But it's a very,
very good question.
There wasn't a sort of formula
for that other than thinking
it might be a play
first with songs.
And I guess some
might say, if you're
going to be purist about it--
which these guys know better
than I-- in the classical
sense of the musical,
you can have songs that are
really one character talking
to another that are moving the
thing forward dramatically,
and while these certainly
have a specific place,
each song dramatically,
they're less--
they're not built that way.
You know?
But, I guess, they called
"American Idiot" a musical,
didn't they?
REBECCA NAOMI JONES: They
called that a rock opera.
NEIL PEPE: Yeah.
Yeah.
There you go.
KECIA LEWIS: Yeah,
this-- I mean everybody
has their different ideas
of what a musical is.
And I did what's considered the
first jukebox musical, which is
"Ain't Misbehavin" on Broadway.
It's very, very different,
because that structure
of the jukebox musical is
that you have a bunch of songs
and then you write a story to
make the songs work when you're
doing them on stage for
people who have paid
$167 for an orchestra seat.
So this is definitely from
an actor's perspective,
a play with music.
REBECCA NAOMI JONES:
Yeah, I would agree.
Even beyond it being
not a jukebox musical,
I think it doesn't
feel like a musical,
because the text is really
what forwards the story along.
No question.
I mean the songs absolutely
serve to aid in that,
but the text-- I mean there's
so much text, first of all,
and I think that's really
where the play comes alive
and all of the
things are revealed.
And, yeah, I think
that the amount of text
is what makes it.
Also I just remembered,
like "American Idiot,"
we didn't have text, that's
why it was a rock opera.
[LAUGHTER]
MAHLET SEYOUM: Thank you.
You can go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming today
and for performing for us.
I'm going to try to ask this
without spoiling anything
for folks who haven't
seen the play with music,
but there's a moment towards
the end in which it's
revealed that Felicia and
Deah are the musicians,
and I think that it was an
incredibly powerful moment
for me, especially
considering the musicianship
is just so incredible
in the show
and the performances overall.
So just a really
focused question
around what types of
conversations were had
or anything discussed around
like how Deah and Felicia
were going to be
kind of showcased
as part of this performance?
NEIL PEPE: It's an
interesting question.
Because ostensibly we
were trying to figure out,
because it's a play about
two amazing women who are--
and we needed amazing
actors, amazing singers,
and both of these women
were incredible musicians.
And so George and I decided
we'll take two of the three.
And so we knew early on that
we wanted to have musicians,
but like you say
the question was,
how to integrate
those musicians.
And we knew we didn't want
to trick the audience.
We didn't want to apologize
for having musicians.
But what we played
with early on in tech
was whether we were going
to see them the whole time.
And we found partly because the
miming was working well enough
between the piano
and the guitar--
it seemed to be working--
that we wanted to hold it back
for a long time.
And it, like you
say, dramatically, I
think it ended up
working, because not only
once you sort of are
allowed to see them,
it becomes this kind
of revelation moment.
And then not for
nothing a lot of people
have said, oh my god, I just
inherently for whatever reason,
they thought it would be men.
And the fact that
all of a sudden it's
two women, two extraordinary
women up there playing
just becomes a whole
other thing that I think
is unifying the piece.
And that was an important
thing for us to do that.
And we were lucky to have
the musicians that we have.
So we did think a lot
about that and try
to figure out how
to integrate it
and I kind of like
where we ended up.
But of course we'd always like
to show the musicians more.
But we hear them, and
we're psyched about that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First I want to say that
the play was incredible.
I loved it.
So in the play, there is at one
point Rosetta says to Marie,
I want you to be an "and."
I want us to be
Rosetta and Marie.
And I noticed that
the play is actually
named Marie and
Rosetta, and I was
wondering if there was some
kind of significance there.
MAHLET SEYOUM: I had a
question about that, too.
NEIL PEPE: I'll let Kecia
talk about that a little bit.
I think there's
something about--
[LAUGHTER]
Do would you want
to talk about it?
KECIA LEWIS: No.
[LAUGHTER]
NEIL PEPE: The only
reason is because I
feel like it became a
big deal, which is one
of the things about this story.
The question is why
did Rosetta-- you know,
Rosetta was a big
star at this point.
Why did she all of a sudden
at this point in her career
pick a very young girl
out of this gospel quartet
or whatever Marie was doing--
what were they called?
The gospel--
REBECCA NAOMI JONES:
The Sunset Four.
NEIL PEPE: She was playing in
New Jersey with a band called
the Sunset Four and
singing with them.
And Rosetta went, I want you.
And not only did
she say, I want you.
She didn't say-- and she makes
a big deal of this in the play.
She's like, I'm not going
to put you back there.
I'm going to put you next to me.
I think it got to
the essence of to me
what the play was about, which
was about why you might need
another person,
not only musically,
but-- Marie says in
a late interview.
She said Rosetta
said she was lonely.
And so there's something
about this play,
about dealing with
loneliness, companionship,
and wanting somebody equal.
One of the things Kecia
and I talked about a lot
is what's the test that Rosetta
is putting Marie through
is part of can I trust you?
Are you somebody who
can tell the truth?
Because I want somebody equal.
And I think Rosanna
needed that, right?
I think she wanted a companion.
KECIA LEWIS: Yeah.
In my research of Rosetta,
I kept seeing over and over
again that throughout her career
she was looking for partners.
She had-- for whatever
reason, and we don't know,
she just did not want
to perform alone.
And so she was always
looking for someone
who was her musical equal and
who she could partner with.
She was very adamant
and said it often
that she did not want to
be considered a great woman
guitarist.
She wanted to be considered
a great guitarist.
And so everybody
that she asked to be
a part of her life in the
different phases of her career,
musically, they were all great
artists in their own right,
because that's what she wanted.
And, yeah, now, I was
like, me answer it?
What?
But yeah, that was the
research that I found.
She always wanted it.
And just in terms of
Marie and Rosetta.
I think that George-- if I
remember correctly, he said,
the play is told from
Marie's perspective.
So in real life they were
the duo, Rosetta and Marie,
but in this reality this
is Marie and Rosetta.
MAHLET SEYOUM: Thank
you guys so much.
We're at time.
Thank you for the performances
and this incredible talk back.
This show is still running.
Do you want to before everyone
leaves just talk about how they
can come see the show and
how they can learn more
about the theater?
NEIL PEPE: So it runs
until October 16th.
And it's at the Atlantic
Theater Company on 20th Street
between 8th and 9th.
You can go to our website,
atlantictheater.org.
It's going really well.
It's gotten terrific reviews.
And audiences are loving it.
We thank those of you
that have come to see it.
These guys are amazing, so
don't miss the opportunity
to see these four extraordinary
performers up there.
And we, as Atlantic,
are grateful to be
in the same building
with Google.
We want to bring all you tech
guys over to the theater world.
And so we would love to
turn you on to what we do,
and we're loving being
turned on to what this
is, which is kind of amazing.
So thanks for having us.
Yeah, thanks for bringing
us your fancy digs.
And come see us.
We would love to have you,
and we're honored to be here.
MAHLET SEYOUM:
Thank you so much.
And thank you guys for coming.
[APPLAUSE]